conozcamos agua no es martín un corredor
de fórmula delta de 18 años conocido
como el hamilton de las favelas nació en
un calendario en un vecindario pobre
comenzó armando vehículos de karting en
la sala de su casa nunca ha corrido
fuera de brasil por mucho tiempo
dependió de la recaudación de fondos de
amigos y familiares para financiar su
carrera durante la pandemia trabajó como
mecánico y piloto de pruebas a cambio de
comida y aún así lleva 21 podios en 44
carreras incluyendo 8 victorias wallace
tiene opción de titularse en la copa
yokohama que corre es que corre su
última válida en diciembre en interlagos
precisamente donde se disputa este fin
de semana la fórmula-1 martins agradece
su apodo de hamilton otro piloto
afrodescendiente por quien se siente
inspirado
creo que es un corredor dedicado a lo
que hace siempre está entrenando ganó
una carrera y ya está pensando en la
próxima así que claramente es devoto de
lo que hace y además esta es su historia
él viene de un vecindario pobre es negro
y es el único piloto negro 1 así que hay
mucho de su historia que es muy
inspirador todo tiene mucho del 15
inspirada